[Musica]
io di solito disegno parchi quindi non
sono proprio abituato a starci sopra
parlare ma io nella vita
io ai miei colleghi ci siamo fatti una
domanda che questa errata anche una
risposta perché tutto il palco per noi
ci sono pochissime cose che non sono un
palco è la nostra grande sfida nella
vita e di farlo ti rendono comprensibile
e di far vedere che in questo c'è una
sua bellezza
prima di presentarmi veramente vi
racconto un po di nostro quotidiano
questo qua vicino a una tranquilla
mattinata a modena poco tempo fa questa
mattina dopo
e questo in realtà non sono due
settimane sono solo dieci giorni dopo e
del concerto che non abbiamo disegnato
per vasco qua vicino
e la cosa interessante è che si fa
niente
in due settimane in due settimane si
crea una città intera con bagni con
nutrizione e appunto con il tutto ciò
vasco finisce 220 mila persone credo non
saprei esattamente ma bologna sarà 300
400 insomma più di metà una città
interamente va a vedere un concerto e
dieci ore dopo
non c'è più niente e totalmente smontato
e resta solamente nei loro palco che
hanno nella mente
dunque questo siamo noi io lo racconto
con molto piacere perchè noi facciamo un
lavoro particolare che non c'era
siamo così figli da dire siamo più
grandi d'europa ma non è non è difficile
perché nessun altro fa il nostro
mestiere
questo siamo noi siamo cristiana che
come da sempre che il mio socio di
maggioranza nonché moglie l'altro socio
dice anche claudio che anche lui è con
noi da sempre a noi appunto abbiamo
scritto designer architetti e artisti a
dir vero non sappiamo bene cosa facciamo
ogni volta che mia mamma lo chiede io
non so rispondere bene balbetta un po
dicevo io non volevo essere dopo
brumotti perché è scorretto trovo lui è
giovane figo racconta una storia
accattivante io ti faccio adesso una
lezioncina accademica sua sul nostro
mondo
allora ho cercato di renderlo un po più
proprio affascinante e mi sono portato
una forchetta
ci ho pensato stamattina perché per voi
questa è una forchetta giusto e invece
no per me non è una forchetta per me un
palco e anche questo per me non è un
piatto ma è di nuovo un palco e forse le
ombre che speravo che si vedessero e
sono sono uno spettacolo o possono
almeno diventarlo e noi facciamo questa
la sfida della nostra della nostra vita
nostra professione proprio questa di
rendere spettacolo o anzi rendere falco
e poi spettacolo tutto quello che
vediamo per noi
ecco questa parte un po più noiosa per
noi tutte le superficie ma anche
verticali o orizzontali tutti possono
hanno la potenzialità possono generare
un parco diventare un palco può accadere
una magia ogni volta che vedete una cosa
un piccolo spettacolo è una piccola
magia vero le magie creano comunità
adesso di nuovo non voglio paragonarci
con brumotti che non è una magia ma una
pazzia e sicuramente crea una comunità e
lui la utilizza dunque nello stessa
maniera
una magia può diventare una storia una
storia diventano comunità e una comunità
può forse cambiare la visione del futuro
o almeno tentarci noi quindi viviamo di
riempire i vuoti e farli diventare
storia
dunque noi la facciamo una quantità
enorme ne disegnano una cinquantina
all'anno che sono il tg1
disegniamo spettacoli alla scala lo
facciamo per la moda per armani
disegniamo delle mostre le mostre
secondo me in questo paese sono una
potenzialità incredibili
l'avrete notato io sono tedesco sono
turista professionale da 27 anni in
italia
dico turista perché magnifico vivere da
turista in italia io vedo solo quello
che mi piace la resto lo ignoro
tranquillamente che è un buon modo di lo
consigliò fra l'altro dunque questo è
una magia che poi in realtà non la
facciamo noi ma la fanno gli artisti che
ha fatto mengoni e lui invece di
utilizzare il palco usa il sopra parco
vola quindi del vuoto dell'area lo
diventa e questo era il concerto
dell'anno scorso invece con tiziano
ferro
abbiamo fatto un tuffo nell'acqua ma
siccome si promette una piscina sul
palco e la piscina che viene su di lui
qua sembra che urli in realtà dice
parolacce perché ovviamente raffreddo e
ultimamente cola sulla sinistra c'è
lorenzo jovanotti per cui abbiamo fatto
diventare il suo parco al forum
l'abbiamo fatto diventare una banana una
stanza da da ballo senza tempo però
voglio raccontarvelo un po meglio la
nostra idea del tutto il parco abbiamo
avuto il piacere di a disegnare
padiglione italia all'expo freddo e non
pensavamo di e di vincere questa sfida
perché non abbiamo raccontato l'idea
complicata all'expo
abbiamo pensato che l'italia è un paese
con grandissimi vuoti e pieni e visto
che mi occupo di vuoti
abbiamo disegnato questo questo fra
l'altro e questo è quasi brumotti questo
e michelle obama da dietro il suo su
didietro insomma la sala degli specchi
da lexus pirico qualcuno di voi abbia
visto era interessante perché
prendeva palermo e venezia e lo buttava
in un grande grandissimo credito scoppio
sono solo specchi e un video quindi lo
spettatore veniva totalmente avvolto
dell'immagine senza farsi delle domande
senza semplicemente ho subito ed era
molto efficiente vivere questo questo
riflesso quindi di nuovo per me tutto è
palco anche solo un riflesso può
diventare parco questa invece è sempre
un padiglione italia e delle sante
perché una sfida su come si può
raccontare il vuoto
qualcuno di voi avrà capito che cosa non
è facilissimo perché il mediterraneo
senza d'italia l'abbiamo tolto perché ci
siamo fatti la domanda ma come sarebbe
il mondo come sarebbe il mediterraneo
senza d'italia era un domanda
interessante e abbiamo fatto delle
interviste che non si vede ma intorno
c'era un agorà una una seduta e abbiamo
preso dei bambini era meno intervistati
e alle risposte sono magnifiche perché i
bambini dicono bene gli svizzeri
avrebbero e spiaggia e genitori dicono
ma avrebbero anche dei migrati chissà
come lo gestiscono
siamo andati avanti avevamo quasi
l'occasione di intervistare
il portavoce di obama e tempi poi alla
fine non ci siamo riusciti ma vorrei
fare la stessa domanda oggi ad un trans
e cosciente che la casa bianca è una
replica di un'architettura totalmente
italiana di palladio neanche tanto
lontano qua quindi insomma come si fa a
raccontare un vuoto così non c'è niente
questa invece la sfida più grande che ci
è stato lanciato e dell albero della
vita dell expo il direttore marco balich
del direttore creativo del padiglione c
è chiesto a disegnare un albero e ci ha
fatto vedere questo vuota in realtà la
foto del vuoto vuoto non ce l'ho perché
non eravamo quelli incaricati non sapevo
neanche che esistesse c'era niente e
abbiamo pensato bene l'albero un bel
simbolo facciamo diventare un albero
palco che problema è per noi facciamo
cuore di mestiere e invece sei settimane
prima dell'expo invece abbiamo pensato
abbiamo cercato un po di altre piazze
perché in fondo era il grande piatto
abbiamo trovato questa questa è un'altra
piazza del campidoglio che conoscete a
roma che vuota e vuota ma pieno di senso
il senso che non è così li dentro non
senza nascosto e vabbè dovrebbe tornare
indietro
michelangelo viene incaricato più o meno
nel 1530 qualche cosa di disegnare st
piazza e lui invece che invece di nastri
di disegnare una pomposa un pomposo
assieme di fontane e come si faceva
verso la fine del rinascimento disegni a
queste 12 spire elegantissime con niente
e mezzo nella sua idea non c'era niente
poi ci hanno messo una statua equestre
ma anche quella non c'è in questo
momento quindi è di nuovo vuoto e perché
lo fa si pensa che lo faccia per questo
perché si pensa che lui conosceva questo
vaso che per i greci era l'ombelico del
mondo
noi ovviamente avevamo già in mente di
chiamare a jovanotti per la canzone ma
l'ombelico del mondo per loro era
portatile cioè il centro del mondo e
caput mundi si portava
ma in giro ed era una cosa che in
effetti dove adesso noi magari non
avremmo messo qua perché decidiamo che
oggi qua il centro del mondo ed è un bel
con sé e quindi per noi questa è entrato
un palco per l'uomo dove l'uomo la prima
volta vi dovete immaginare alla fine del
rinascimento l'uomo va in mezzo capisce
io c'entro io io posso io posso sono
connesso con tutto il resto
una vera sfida questo ma un soldato e
torna indietro mi fai 20 kadiri questo
ci siamo domandati come si fa cresce un
albero su questo ci vuole una regia
intelligente e l'abbiamo trovata
l'abbiamo trovata in fibonacci che un
altro come dire grande classico
accademico sono sa cosa dire fibonacci
funziona quasi sempre questa bellissima
sequenza la conoscete è stato utilizzato
per milioni di applicazioni per la
crescita in borsa per la crescita degli
alberi alla fine se si sommano i
quadrati diventa anche il famoso taglio
crediti a natalia ori con italiano e si
pensa che lui la conoscesse perché
disegno troppo invitante e quindi aveva
pensato invece di disegnarlo generiamo
utilizziamo fibonacci come regista come
drammaturgo
noi crediamo che anche l'architettura
abbia una drammaturgia a loro nome
regista adesso vediamo se parte no va
bene fa niente arriva questo firmato qua
questo è proprio come lo abbiamo
generato si capisce
all'inizio che siamo ancora nel
campidoglio
ma le spire si compongono dal pavimento
di michelangelo e diventano piano piano
l'albero della vita utilizzando la
sequenza di fibonacci e alla fine è
diventato questo questo erano i primi
schizzi una volta capito concert ci
piaceva tantissimo che l'italia non lo
chiamavano sempre un simbolo del
neorinascimento io voglio sempre di e
spero che nel rinascimento arriva fra
poco perché ci serve
e l'idea è che l'italia comunque cresce
segua anch'essa questo
questo momento di di luminosità allora
per i filmati siamo purtroppo un po in
ritardo si è ed è questo l'avete visto
sicuramente la vita vista in qualche
maniera e ci siamo domandati cosa è
successo lì mai un palco ma una piazza
ma che cos'è questo oggetto è perché ha
funzionato per noi era totalmente
inaspettato noi ci siamo tuffati e
abbiamo provato e ci siamo dati anche
una risposta purtroppo sarà un po lungo
non pensavo quindi loro non lo faccio a
sfruttare solo all'inizio assieme con la
musica è riuscita a creare una magia
riuscita a creare una comunità e questa
comunità era talmente forte che ha vinto
su tutte le critiche e soprattutto
abbiamo avuto più highlight l'albero di
natale che mi rendo conto è importante
quindi la comunità
probabilmente ha cambiato attraverso la
cristo sharing l'idea dell'expo all idea
che avevano dell'expo e quindi noi ne
siamo come dire fortunati e orgogliosi e
ci siamo anche domandati ma ha cambiato
qualcosa milano
ora io credo di si io credo che milano
dopo l'exor cambiato sicuramente non è
cambiato grazie all'albero ma noi
abbiamo visto che è invece qualcosa è
cambiato ho visto l'altro giorno questo
sui navigli a milano che un graffitaro
sponsorizzato da unicredit
la messa nella skyline pur essendo noi
questo sempre paragone fra membro motti
e l'albero e 37 metri il bus khalifa e
800 metri
pur essendo molto piccolo in qualche
maniera ci siamo riusciti ad essere
nella skyline e ci sono altre cose molto
carine qualcuno l'ha piazzato
ovviamente con una simulazione nella
piazza di and sand in piazza loreto che
che una piazza pericolosa no una storia
alla fine della guerra importante quindi
chiunque l'abbia fatto non noi è una
visionaria e l'hanno messo sott'acqua
non ho messo una scultura sott'acqua
vicino alla coltivazione subacquea e
anche lì è insomma un grande onore per
noi ce lo hanno chiesto da las vegas e
l'abbiamo dato hanno fatto un mega
festona las vegas hanno fatto le
copertine senza chiederlo nelle ferrovie
dello stato hanno fatto un videogioco
l'hanno fatto e leggo e da qualche parte
artisti personale se lo so non sono
fatte dunque io poi avevo giurato di
tornare a forchetta
io spero di essere uscito a farvi capire
che in fondo non è una forchetta ma la
sfida è farla diventare a quello che poi
l'italia con le direi la paese della
forchetta ci ho messo anni a mangiare la
pasta io e questo invece quello che ha
messo mie figlie alla fine c'è
ovviamente se non c'è palco sono c'è
storia anche noi di forma i miei soci
non ci siamo quindi per noi e palco ergo
sum
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]